this episode of fun science is brought
to you by squarespace horror movies
rollercoasters scary videogames bungee
jumping ghost stories tobogganing
haunted houses Halloween why just just
why or as one of our viewers Vanessa
squeakers and asked why is it that some
people enjoy things that scare them it's
a great question
one that's especially worth answering
during this spooky time of year
why do we enjoy being scared well
because we here at fun science like to
go the extra mile we're not gonna just
tell Vanessa the answer we're going to
show her in this week's episode on
science it's fun yeah
to start us off it's worth saying that
although many people would consider fear
to be a negative emotion it's actually
one of the main reasons that humans are
still here today imagine two cavemen one
who when they hear a rustle in the
bushes runs for their life while the
other one thinks it's probably nothing
for a girl a mugger out of the two
cavemen I'm sure you can imagine which
one is more likely to survive so sure
fear is a very useful emotion but it's
still not a very pleasant one right so
why is it feeling that some people
actively seek out well imagine how you
would feel if you were the caveman that
managed to escape the lion while a
moment ago you were absolutely terrified
now you feel great I mean you just
stared death in the face and survived
its kind of feel good
well that sense of relief is just one of
the reasons that people seek health
things that scare them that's why when I
did a bungee jump years ago I was
terrified before I jumped but as soon as
I landed I instantly wanted to do it all
over again however knowing that you're
going to feel relieved after you come
out of a scary film isn't going to be
enough to sustain you through the whole
thing in order to enjoy a horror movie
you need to also enjoy the feeling of
being frightened while you
so how does that work guys what
happened to the lights hello Dave is
that you when you experience fear lots
of different things happen to your body
the palms sweat your pupils dilate your
heart rate increases your breath
quickens your muscles tense your
attention focuses and your brain emits
different chemicals such as dopamine and
adrenaline but did you know that this
list of effects is exactly what you'd
expect to see in a person experiencing
intense excitement so although you may
not notice it these two seemingly very
different emotions actually feel very
similar and it only takes one change to
be able to turn fear into something you
can enjoy that thing is control
so while that is indeed frightening to
watch I know that I'm not in any danger
because hey it's just a video so long as
I know that I'm safe
I can enjoy the fear this even works for
activities that are high-risk such as
skydiving when it comes to something
like this all of the training and
precautions that lead up to it help
prepare your brain for what's coming in
fact several studies have shown that the
brain reacts completely differently to a
predictable threat compared to an
unpredictable one all of which allows
you to enjoy the experience of doing
something scary and like let's say this
guy so there you have it we enjoy being
scared because when we feel safe that
feeling of fear isn't all that different
from excitement so Vanessa does that
answer your question
Vanessa
Vanessa I'm sorry I scared you earlier
next
[Music]
it seems then that being scared isn't
such a weird thing for us to enjoy after
all but maybe there's something that you
enjoy or have a passion for that's a
little more unique for me personally I
love nothing more than seeing people
share their excitement for something
that they care about and building a
website with Squarespace is a great way
to do that they have lots of lovely
templates which makes it super easy to
create and share exactly what you love
in your voice no matter how weird so
start your free trial today and go to
Squarespace com forward slash fun
science to get 10% off your first
purchase also if you made it this far
I'm assuming you're a fan of fun science
so why not consider supporting the show
directly and becoming a patron you'll
find more information about that at
patreon.com forward slash fun sites
thank you very much guys I'll see you
soon